is I look just giving the 10 I mean he's
confessing to her you know he walked
away from this four years ago you really
don't have a case and he's willing to
give you everything he had that you
can't take because that had the statute
of limitations of that had run out way
long ago and he's doing all this
voluntarily nobody could say well we
recommend it was up to the judge and
walked through the corner and the judge
is like mr. Valdez my intentions to
sentence you to life sentence young man
you had died in a federal prison and I
looked down so your honor you can only
give me what God wants to give me and
the truth of man is if my life change
doesn't change I don't give a damn where
I die prison don't scare me so you know
a year went by and I ended up getting I
was given the ten years because my
attorneys were able to argue in the
prosecutor agreed that I had cooperated
extensively by giving him so all of my
assets
initially they gave you lyfe no no no
that's what I went to because you and
father judge to plead right let's call
your arraignment and you plead guilty
not guilty
mmm so I went in there to plea guilty
when I go in there to PLT the judge or
anyone does the judge tells you what you
are exposed to what you can get but you
know they didn't they knew that it
wasn't that I got caught and I'm sorry
the good thing I had I knew that I could
one of the thing that would have helped
me back from doing that was if I had to
testify against anybody because you hear
about my first when I got arrested in
Panama was tortured for 28 days yeah I
want to go okay I'm gonna go yeah back
to that so but I walked out uh I went
back to prison and I said I got a choice
I can either sleep 12 hours it may say
you sleep 12 hour you sleep after you
sent us away mm-hm
or I can do something about my life so
I've made myself believe which is all
all your mindset right your whole life
is your mindset how you look at the
world it doesn't matter this is water
what matters is how is my mind looking
at that water does it look at I can make
a dollar off of it or does it look I
like wow I'm died of thirst it can
satisfy me or man maybe that water is
burning heat in this a plastic he's got
cancer it's all in your mind right so
how you look at it so I said I'm gonna
make believe I'm in a monastery mm-hmm
begin to study I got another bachelor's
degree I told myself Greek I started
half of my master's when I was released
from prison went back to Wheaton College
in Illinois and I finished my masters
then I went to Loyola you know she got a
PhD when I graduated I was one of five
Hispanics in the whole country with a
PhD in New Testament in ethics and uh I
was named a Hispanic doctoral student
America by the Pew foundation two years
in a row
and then I was recruited by every
University and then I looked at myself
in $90,000 and I got six kids how do i
because for Cubans education everything
right so I and then my dad had died and
my children that little girl and her two
other siblings were living in Georgia
and how many know the noise and I'm
getting this job in California and I'm
like I told my wife I'm gonna move to
Georgia and I'm gonna be a full-time dad
to those kids
and she's like what are you gonna do I
mean your dream is to teach I said yeah
that's been my dream for the last seven
years I said but my kids don't care
about my dream how they're gonna
remember me dad does send the check
every month and had a good summer I want
to be there and I did and I moved they
know what to do and I start a little
cleaning company in the big field of my
house yeah taking out water damage and
fire damage and cleaning toilets and
wrote my book it was a best-seller at
that time and so I was out there
preaching in there the same time I was
either cleaning carpet and then I in ten
years I built it into a multi-million
dollar national international company
the cleaning business yeah we had with
the jobs in London with the jobs in
Grand Cayman all over the United States
and then my my customers were
governments and at the end I'm sitting
there on the last job and I'm in
Louisiana and we had just built the
first Catholic Catholic Church inside
any United States person at Angola a
place that no one a prison coin go lie
in in Louisiana you were building Church
inside my villages I don't want it
Cypress yeah this was just when we built
our company we made a we made a decision
me and two other partners my brother and
my other partner
we give 10% of the top to our foundation
to impact other people's life because I
determined that what makes a great
companies not great technology great
employees great customer is the company
that gets back and and so we create a
foundation that I ran and I still run
today and and one of the things that
foundation did is build this church
because it's a prison that there was 2/3
of angelical chapels but there was no
Catholic chapel Luciano very Catholic
state and and those men are never gonna
go home sixty-five hundred men Oh mostly
sentence to the life or death and in
Louisiana life means you die there three
cemeteries you know it's what they did
the movie was dead men walking
hmm so we had just finished a huge job
three years job and I sat there i you
know I lived in a motor home for those
three years I had a big motor home which
was my office because our job see they
were governed we had to go and park like
right you know there's no be a hurricane
a national fire whatever the catastrophe
could be and and I'm sitting there and I
just thought to myself you know I got
two kids left two young kids left and my
other four literally don't know me right
my oldest son by the time he was 13 have
been in jail ten years and yeah we're
very close all of our very close I've
educated all of them and I told my wife
Anna quit and she's like you're gonna
what I said yeah I'm gonna stop I'll
retire 56 and she's like man you worked
your life to get to this point and we
were we're making millions you know we
had jets again I had a 90-foot yacht and
I said look I don't need a jet I don't
need the yacht and I got enough money to
live very comfortably the rest of my
life
and I don't need no more zeros and I
quit and I went to run the foundation in
Mexico we took my kids and we moved to
Cozumel Mexico five years and I wanted
my kids to learn a different culture I
wanted them to see my wife and I grew up
poor and also we were not poor we're
very wealthy and we're living in you
know in a mansion and and we had fancy
vacation and private jets
and my kids going to the best school and
I looked at her and I like even though
we were very careful and we never give
her kids more than a hundred dollars
every Christmas and they say you take
that and you get three gifts Jesus got
three you get three you're no better
than Jesus and they all were great with
that but three what I said Jesus got
three gifts that's all you get
oh okay so I thought I need to show him
what the real world is and in the world
we live now is now reeled this is not
real and this is a fantasy world and say
there's good Cozumel for one year so we
bought a house over there an apartment
on the ocean and and we stayed five and
we create a foundation to the foundation
we created a program the kids had a lot
problem with obesity and in drugs and my
wife and I was doing Ironman and we
created a program through Ironman ICO I
say no to drugs or V city and violence
so we did we would take these kids start
with my daughter actually my son they
used to do iron kids so they're good at
a track and then we I started using gang
techniques like what the Yanks they
loved colors right so a t-shirt with a
color so I gave them a white teacher I
said everybody starts running we hire a
coach and here's how you're gonna
advance in this program I don't give a
damn how fast you are in life that's not
gonna get you anywhere what's gonna get
you somewhere in life is that you are a
good human being and then you got good
morals and you got good work ethics so
we're gonna create a point chart and
you're gonna get points for number one
showing on time and that was a that was
the biggest challenge the whole program
in Mexico getting kids to show up in
time and number two if you bring another
kid you get a program if you're
overweight then we had a nutritionist
and we put you in a program and as you
lose weight we go ahead and you get
points you know how you treat teachers
how you treat your mother and as you get
points then we give them a green jersey
we taught them how to swim and then they
get more more points and we give them a
red jersey and now they can ride a bike
and women bike so now that we're doing
triathlon we started with two kids my
daughter and my son and couple kids from
school in my time we left
we had 300 kids that had lost amazing
amount of weight that were on a Friday
night I have pictures of my facebook
these kids on a Friday night working
their butts off a dark I'm saying like
what kid in the world Friday night it's
not he is sweating on the track trying
to become better you know and and it
worked and it was and it was amazing and
then my wife wanted us to come back to
the States
because she wanted the kids to go to
high school in the United States and we
came back five years ago and I was
happily retired I was like I walked my
dog in the morning I exercise for an
hour and a half and by 11 o'clock I was
done for the day man that was good
that's great and then through a series
of event it's over like God called me
hey I did a big event in Houston and and
this I didn't realize I was for big CEOs
Catholic CEOs and this guy asked me like
what are you doing I said oh well I'm
retired he's like really and what do you
do I said well I get up at five o'clock
every day of my life I feed the kids I
walk the dog and I exercise for an hour
and a half and I'm done
[Laughter]